design matters and it matters for
governments
like companies countries spend a lot of
time and money on branding themselves so
that they can communicate clearly to
their citizens and also so that they can
set themselves apart from others
now
when talking about how things look it's
always important to understand that
taste and design is subjective with the
exception of my own which is
unparalleled in its sophistication but
if we establish what goals governments
are trying to reach with their design it
becomes a lot easier to determine
objectively what a good or bad design
decision is
and there is one country in particular
assuming you think good government
design is functional and minimalist
design that stands out on top
and that's the netherlands
if good government design is that which
brands a nation is strong to the rest of
the world a country that's probably more
fitting is france
its logo includes the country's most
important symbols the red white and blue
with the blue being since recently
changed back to its traditional color
and it also includes france's most
important national icon
the french design goes a step further
though by also communicating their
ground values more explicitly than what
may be typical even when compared with
stereotypically louder
yet still nations together as one
american family
e pluribus unum
out of many
one
alternatively if good government design
means that it shows off your unique and
immediately recognizable assets the
netherlands also isn't first in line
it's not that tulips aren't great in all
or that the dutch sky isn't beautiful
but a country like estonia which is
known as one of the first that
completely digitized its own government
sometimes does a better job looking like
an e-commerce company than an actual
government
another example of a country that is
very effective at marketing its own
personal brand would be sweden which has
seemingly delegated all of its branding
to private industry when people hear the
name bolermann few think about this
beautiful lake in small and sweden
instead
most people think about this
a toilet brush for us who work in
tourism this is a bit problematic and
what's worse
is that boleman is just the tip of the
iceberg
also if good government design is
defined by strictly upholding certain
rules and standards almost to the point
of insanity to everyone's amazement and
surprise the germans and the swiss are
probably the leaders
no what makes dutch government design
good is its functionality and simplicity
that comes close to but definitely is
not boring it stays uniform while also
giving room for each individual ministry
and it immediately communicates to the
dutch people that something is part of
the dutch state
it does this while also remaining very
flat and simple which also immediately
reminds you of the country
in the typical dutch obsession with
being as normal as possible even the
national serif font looks like it's
trying its hardest not to be a serif
in 2007 dutch prime minister balkande
who was always known for his especially
creative unique and eccentric
personality
made the surprising decision to
centralize government design and get rid
of the hundreds of individually unique
government associated logos in order to
make a more quite literally monolithic
block
case
this wasn't typical as there were only a
few countries that had actively tried to
centralize their branding schemes and as
we can expect from humanity and
particularly the dutch a lot of people
were critical
you had of course the natural debate on
whether the government was spending too
much money and the dutch military which
as you know has always been considered
the netherlands strongest asset and
really unique characteristic on the
world stage was so opposed that the
government conceded to give each
military branch their own special logo
one of the main criticisms however which
is what gets to the heart of why the
design is actually pretty good is that
the dutch government design is just too
bland
but this is the wrong way to look at it
it is not a new thing to question that
what you may gain and function will be
lost in individuality it's an endless
discussion and there are plenty of
examples of where companies have given
up creative expression for almost
unnecessary simplicity
but some could say that governments
should be judged by different standards
for many people not including those who
waste their incredibly valuable time
consuming political content online
governments can be considered to be
doing their best job when its citizens
aren't thinking much about it
take emergency services this is one of
the areas where government probably does
want to make sure it's visible and
clearly demarcated in daily life
the solution for them are funky stripes
which give the impression that there are
more visible emergency services without
coming off as intimidating or relying on
the cheap use of neon which many other
european police vehicles do
unfortunately there are still plenty of
dutch people who don't appreciate the
design of dutch emergency services like
i do but there are plenty of other
examples of good dutch government design
for example letters each comes off as
subtle enough except for the dark blue
which is immediately associated with the
dutch tax authorities also conveniently
the only important letter you actually
need to open
and there are some designs that are even
more subtle
if i show you this logo and try to
imagine that you've never seen it before
in your life what does it tell you
nothing but of course most europeans
know immediately that it signals the
deutsche ban which is germany's national
rail service
and the same is true for the tej it
doesn't immediately tell you at face
value that it's france's high-speed rail
service
but what if i show you this logo
it's subtle sure but you could also
easily imagine yourself making the
connection between this and the
netherlands national rail company
the ns logo is also not so obvious to
the point that it's explicit like the
czech republic's national rail company
all of this is not to say that dutch
design is perfect no there are plenty of
things that i with my childish desire to
come off as intelligent and worldly as
possible can't even really act like i
understand either
for example personnel
it is what it is
or better yet the recently upgraded
national parliament which looks more
like an ikea-filled dentist waiting room
along with a bunch of rocks glued onto
the wall
and there are plenty of other
governments that are also pretty
functional
where each ministry in the netherlands
can technically choose their own
department's color even though that
color won't be explicitly acknowledged
as theirs the uk does have uniquely
color-coded ministries which is much
more slick in my unquestionable and
authoritative opinion
where the germans may have phenomenal
and groundbreaking industrial design the
swiss placement in grids and the
italian's design that makes you feel
incredibly inferior the dutch navigate a
very fine line between fun simple and
sober
and for a government that probably
doesn't want to come off as anything
more than normal that's probably
perfectly okay
no
[Music]